-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
Now, we are going to
get to the news.
President Biden today held
a bilateral meeting with
Italian Prime Minister
Mario Draghi to reaffirm
the partnership between
the two countries.
Though I think he misunderstood
which partnership.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden has reportedly
told his national security
officials that
recent press leaks about
intelligence sharing
with Ukraine need to stop
and could further inflame
tensions with Russia.
So, remember, the Ukrainian
people have our full support,
but if anyone asks,
no, they don't.
[ Laughter ]
Congressional Republicans are
reportedly split over what to do
if the Supreme Court officially
overturns Roe v. Wade.
Apparently, they can't decide
between a ticker-tape parade
or a dance party.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a very fair point,
but I understand why
it was a huge bummer.
[ Laughter ]
The Senate passed a bill
yesterday to expand security
for Supreme Court justices,
and just in time.
Did you see how close that
lunatic got to Clarence Thomas?
[ Laughter ]
150 personal items that belonged
to the late Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
recently sold in an auction
for over $800,000,
though I think some of
Kavanaugh's stuff got mixed in.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Texas are looking
for a man who allegedly
burglarized a home and then
mowed the front and back lawns
before fleeing the scene.
Police describe the suspect
as your dad.
[ Laughter ]
A dog that escaped from a yard
in Brooklyn over a week ago
was spotted swimming
in the East River
then walking through
the Battery Tunnel
before he was rescued from
the parking lot
of a Home Depot in New Jersey.
Though I'm not sure "rescued"
is the right word.
It sounds more like
he was apprehended.
[ Laughter ]
"Who told you where to find me?"
Authorities in Nevada have
reported finding several sets of
human remains over the last week
in Lake Mead as water levels
drop amid an ongoing drought.
On the upside, the Mafia is now
very invested
in stopping climate change.
[ Laughter ]
Artist Andy Warhol's silk-screen
portrait of Marilyn Monroe sold
yesterday at auction
for $195 million
and at Old Navy for $6.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Starbucks added
a new drink to its menu today,
which is cold-brew coffee topped
with chocolate foam
and sweetened with
vanilla syrup.
It's also their first drink
to come with the bathroom key.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that was the monologue,
everybody.